[Applaudissements]
payet moi j'ai pris que des casquettes
en bois dirait et collante et ados
oui moi aussi absolument pas mon truc je
n'avais pas là cette chose là dedans
c'est un petit peu jobin un peu oui oui
je danse mais c'est un peu comme on va
pour montrer je danse pour être avec
quelqu'un tu as ce jeudi repas offert le
l'animal qui attire tu vois des trucs
vis un moment comme ça non vous dénoncez
comme et discrètement comme ça dans
votre coin si je suis avec quelqu'un
mais j'ai pas matin encore une fois à
sortir mais plus mais tout le truc parce
que je n'y arrive pas vous pourriez
lancer un pont avec enora ou pas avec
qui à kenora bien sûr je vais vous dire
que c'est fort c'est surtout les genres
et de musiciens puis sur un bouton comme
vous voulez pas ce que vous voulez quel
genre de musique jean c'est vous qui
décidez c'est sûr que tu veux addax
l'eau a laissé au final est ce que vous
voulez je te fais
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci est je crois que franchement mais
l'échangé très cool pouvez pas savoir
comme je vous aime mais vraiment fait le
chien vous avez la place bien sûr mais
je vous dirai rien c'est comme ça j'aime
bien il est agile le jean reno jean reno
bâton va nous chanter deux chansons
j'aurai le patch micro main merci jean
reno va nous chanter tout de suite du
world sunshine vous inquiétez pas je
vais pas vous demander ce dont vous vous
sentez repoux pas neuf mais là un truc
[Musique]
le soutien
n'empêche pas les paroles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
touche pas à mon poste
le gac la zone de son nom mais c'est ça
le gars il peut chanter d'après c'est le
seul gars qui peut sauter les sardines
au resto classe c'était pas un sou alors
je vous l'aï pris au mit en mi mineur
j'aurais pris ça en aurait diez
d'immeubles où vous voulez aller tout de
suite on va cueillir camille combal
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comment ça va emmanuel georges génial
top bourrel voix vous connaissez
l'émission touche pas à mon poste ou pas
oui merci à d'accord donc pouvait
laisser camille combal reconnaît camille
pin c'est ça vous l'aimez bien je la
donne merci stéphane à peine de faire
genre parce que c'est le fayot ans a
fallu regarder ce que j'ai pour les
quatre ans
[Applaudissements]
viva
c'est le placo